while the equal pay act passed in 1963
it made gender-based wage discrimination
illegal
but more than 50 years later women are
still paid less than men
and the pandemic could be making the
situation even worse
michelle miller explains
personal trainer and cameroonian
immigrant simone chuke knows the
importance
of working hard on average i would do
about 20 sessions
so about five to eight sessions a day so
when the pandemic hit
how did it impact your business it was
really
it was really bad we just kind of like
scale down to like nothing so enough to
like pay your rent
and pay food and that's it during this
economic downturn women have suffered
more job losses than men
and women still in the workforce
continue to face a grim reality
they also make less than men i know
a couple of male trainers who have been
training as much as
i have been training and i think we more
or less have the same experience
and they are able to charge more per
session
and it's always so weird like i don't
know why but as a woman is always so
hard to kind of impose my price
in 2018 women earned about 82 cents for
every dollar
earned by men for black women 62 cents
and for latina women just 54 cents
this is a driver of the wealth gap which
can mean a woman at retirement
age accumulates about one million
dollars less
than her male counterpart i think it has
to do with a lot of
antiquated gender norms and roles and
expectations
that we have around who is the primary
breadwinner in families
nicole mason is the president and ceo of
the institute for women's policy
research
coven 19 has hit women particularly hard
why the sectors that were hardest hit by
the pandemic
were sectors where women were
predominantly inner focus so
the service sector education health
services those sectors were hardest hit
and when you couple that with the pay
gap and lack of savings
economic shock like the pandemic really
hurts and cripples
working women especially lower wage
women
she says shutdowns across the country
put working moms
at a disadvantage there's no school
there's no daycare
and women are expected to do it all
they're expected to work 40 hours a week
and still be the primary
caregiver and it's just an impossible
situation for most women especially
women
who don't have the option of working
remotely or home
like heisha gonzalez a mom of two from
connecticut
it's been a struggle trying to decide
what to do she will likely leave her job
as a para educator to homeschool her
children this fall
that's definitely going to leave a gap
in my resume
i don't know how it's going to be going
back if they're going to have me back
and then
obviously you know the lack of income
and financial goals
that has to take a step back for a while
the pay gap persists because
gender-based pay discrimination although
illegal
is widespread women also work in
lower paying jobs and might not have
access to paid family leave
or affordable child care so the pay gap
won't close if we do nothing
it won't close for another 40 years for
black and latino women it won't close
for more than 100 years so a century
so essentially my daughter or my
daughter's daughter won't see pay equity
in their lifetime
this conversation that we're having
around the pay gap and wealth building
and also building an economy a more
equitable economy that works for
everyone i think
the pandemic and covet has really
provided us an opportunity
to think about women workers including
simone chuke
hopefully things get better so my goal
is to create
videos online on my website where people
can subscribe and have access to my
workouts
like so many others she's trying to
salvage her business
but plans to move out of new york city
because she can no longer
afford it i want to work like i just
want work even when i say i need
assistance
i don't need somebody to give me money i
just need work you know
it's interesting to see how many of
these issues the pandemic has put an
extra spotlight on including the wage
gap
yeah such an important story and you
hope that the people who have the
ability to change that
will also be enlightened if you will